( intro music )
( applause )
Sanga: Imagine if your
sister or daughter
had to miss school twice a week
to walk 10 kilometers
to gather wood
for your family to cook with.
Millions of girls across
the African continent
go through this every day.
As a matter of
fact, my own sister
had to miss school
twice a week, every week
to go and gather
wood for my family.
But at first,
I thought this wasn't
a problem for me to solve,
until one day.
I used to work for one
of the biggest banks
in Uganda as an accountant.
In Uganda, after
you finish school
you leave your village and
go to find a job in the city.
So that meant that
I was away from home
for long periods of time.
After six months
without going home,
I made the journey to
go and see my mother.
On my way home,
I met my kid sister
carrying wood on a day she
was supposed to be in school.
At first I wasn't surprised,
because I also
carried wood as a kid.
But when she saw me,
she started crying.
She cried so hard that
at first I got confused.
I thought maybe my
mother was sick,
or something terribly
wrong had happened to her.
Or I even thought that maybe she
was overwhelmed with joy because
I had not come home
for a long time.
( laughter )
But when I helped her put
the wood down and asked her,
"Why are you crying?"
she said, "I'm tired of
missing school to gather wood."
She told me, "You see, all
the forests here are gone,
so the distances
keep increasing.
First of all,
I can't go to school,
but I am also physically
tired of doing that.
It's hurting me."
So I told her, "Don't worry."
I gave her a promise.
"Let's go home.
I will tell mother,
and convince her to allow me
to take you back with
me to the capital city
where I worked,
and I will find you
a boarding school where you
don't need to gather wood."
She was happy,
so we went home.
But when I proposed
this to my mother,
she rejected it.
She said, "All you
guys are grown."
I have five sisters, but
all of them are married.
Most of them married
between the age of 13 and 15.
So she was the only
one left at home.
My mother said,
"Do you want me,
I'm an old woman.
Do you want me to be the one
going to find this wood?"
So that failed.
After my visit I went back
to my normal job in the city.
But I'm a strong
believer in education.
Education has changed my life.
I wouldn't be here if
I didn't go to school.
And 99% of kids
I started life with
didn't get a chance to
continue with education.
When I go to the village
and see the lives they live,
it's so heartbreaking.
Most of them look like
five times my age.
They have 15 children already.
They are stuck in poverty there.
So seeing my sister
on the verge of missing
the only opportunity
she had to improve her life,
broke my heart,
and I couldn't sleep.
I would see her
at night in dreams,
calling my name,
asking me to help her,
until I couldn't
take it anymore,
and I left my job.
But I'm an accountant
by training.
I'm not an engineer.
So my first question was,
"What are you going to do?"
But then I asked myself,
"If I stay here in this bank,
I'm busy all the time.
I can't find time
to research anything.
Let me just go and see
if I can find a solution."
Actually my boss,
when he was signing
my resignation letter, said,
"Sanga, you are
acting like a madman,
but I am going to
sign your resignation.
Go and fail.
I've given you
a period of six months.
If you fail, come back.
Your job will be here."
I said, "Thank you, sir."
I went, but in my heart I knew
I wasn't going to come back.
So I went...
The first thing I did is I went
to one of the
universities in Uganda,
which I attended,
called Makerere,
and went to the
engineering department,
and looked for the
professor that headed
the engineering department,
and told him that I was
trying to find a solution
to the energy crisis in Uganda.
The first thing he
told me, he said,
"Young man, I am a professor.
I know many things,
but I have actually
never done anything
with my hands,
so I also don't
know what to do."
( laughter )
"But what I will do for you is
I will give you literature.
I have a lot of papers.
I have magazines."
So he went to his
office and got a box
full of papers, and said,
"Go and read.
If you find
something interesting,
come back to me.
I will maybe help you."
So I took the box and spent
an entire week in the house,
reading through these papers,
until I came across an
article that talked about
some trials that were
done in the Amazon forest
where indigenous people
were turning waste,
like leafy materials,
into fuel and fertilizers.
That was very exciting to me.
As a matter of fact, as
I was reading through that
I could see a pile
of sugar cane waste
outside my window.
Uganda is predominantly
agriculture.
Everyone has a farm.
They grow food,
mostly subsistence.
But there is a lot of
waste that no one uses.
I was very excited.
I went to the
professor and said,
"I found a solution."
He said, "Calm down, young man.
I told you I'm a professor.
I don't know how to help you.
But I will take
you to my class."
So he took me to his class,
and made me stand in
front of the class,
and said, "This young man
is crazy enough to think
that he can solve the energy
crisis of this country.
Who wants to help him?"
And everyone's hand went up.
( laughter )
So he took me out and said,
"Okay, I'm going to
choose 10 students
that I'm really
sure are very good,
and you can use
our facilities here.
But I warn you, we don't
have any research budget
for that kind of work here.
So you have to fund everything.
If there's need
for buying things,
be prepared to fund that."
I said, "No problem."
We started with the 10 students.
We tried many things
that didn't work.
I actually left
the bank with about
1.5 million Uganda shillings.
That's roughly $500.
It was gone in like two months,
and we had not really found
a solution that worked.
As a young man, I had bought
a few expensive things,
like a television set,
a refrigerator, a sofa set,
those things that when
you are coming out of red
you are like,
"If I first get my job,
I will get all these things."
I first watched some
television when I was 15,
so the first thing I
bought was a television,
because I had never
really had a television.
I went home and phoned a buyer,
brought him to my house,
said, "This is what I have.
How much are you giving me?"
I found a good buyer.
He brought a pickup
and took everything,
and I had some money.
The challenge came when my
girlfriend came to visit...
( laughter )
... and found me in an empty
house, and asked me,
"What is the problem?
Have you moved?"
( laughter )
"You didn't tell me."
I said, "No, I sold everything."
She said, "Are you
out of your mind?
I thought you were mad
when you left your job,
but now I am totally
sure you are crazy.
You need to check yourself
in a mental institution."
( laughter )
She slammed the door.
I didn't see her
again for six months.
But the good story is,
I got the money.
I went back to the university,
and with the help of those
10 university students,
we built two pieces
of technology.
One is a kiln, and another
one is a briquetting machine.
I will be telling
you about those
pieces of technology later.
But that was the foundation.
And with that, I was
able to start my company,
Eco-Fuel Africa,
which basically works
with local communities
to turn locally sourced
farm and municipal waste
into clean cooking fuel
and organic fertilizers,
and this is how
the business works.
The business is
based on basically
the two pieces of technology.
One is a kiln.
These are very basic
pieces of technology.
The kiln is made out
of old oil drums.
We go to slums and townships
and collect or buy
old oil drums,
remodify them and
give them a chimney,
and design them in
a way that limits
the amount of oxygen that goes
into the combustion process.
We go back to the villages,
find farmers with the
help of local leaders,
train these farmers
how to use these kilns,
and after the training
we give them a kiln
on a lease to own basis.
The farmers take
these kilns back
and start converting their
farm waste into a powder.
We call this powder a char,
and we teach these farmers
to sieve this powder on screens.
Approximately 80% of
the powder they make
goes through the sieve, and
we buy that from the farmers.
The coarser portion that
remains on top of the screen
can be used--
We teach farmers how to
mix that with compost,
and they can return
it to their gardens
as a fertilizer called bio-char.
So they don't have
to buy fertilizers,
and they can renew their soils
and increase their
soil fertility.
As a matter of fact,
recently we made a survey,
and most of these
farmers were able
to increase their
harvest by over 30%
using these fertilizers.
After buying this
powder from the farmers,
we take it to our
production facilities.
We built a number of
production facilities
in these villages, where we
use the briquetting machines
that the students
helped us build,
to compress them into briquettes
that people can use to cook.
Our briquettes are
50% cheaper than
traditional charcoal from wood.
They burn cleaner, and
they burn 30 minutes longer
compared to wood,
so people can save money.
Users of our fuel save
about $200 a year,
because of using this fuel.
Because of that, they
can cook regular meals.
They don't have to deplete
forests to cook food,
and they don't have to suffer
from indoor air pollution.
But we don't sell our fuel
directly to the consumers.
We've created
a distribution network
where we work with local women
to sell this fuel back
to the communities.
These are everyday women.
We go to these communities.
We talk to local leaders.
They help us identity
marginalized women.
Most of our women retailers
are single mothers,
widows, people who
would not ordinarily
find any other job,
have no marketable skills.
We train them and build
them a well-branded kiosk,
which acts like
a one-stop shop center...
I think my English is right.
... in the village, and people
can come and buy fuel,
but we also allow them
to sell other things
like tomatoes, oranges, food,
so that people get that one-stop
center shopping experience.
It makes it easy for them
to sell enough briquettes.
We've already created
460 women retailers
in these communities.
These make about $152
a month in income.
This is middle-class
income actually in Uganda.
It's more than what
the government of Uganda
pays primary school
teachers, for example.
With this income,
these women can
send their children to school.
They can buy food
for their families,
take their children to hospital,
and improve their livelihoods.
We have made some strides.
We started from scratch
a few years ago.
We now have over 2,500
farmers with our kilns,
the kilns I showed you,
that supply us with the char.
We have 460 women distributors,
and over 100,000
people use our fuel
on a daily basis in Uganda.
But we are still
a drop in the ocean,
because currently our
biggest challenge is
the demand for our fuel
exceeds our supply by far.
Uganda has 35 million people.
We are now reaching
only 100,000 plus.
We are still very small compared
to the demand out there.
The biggest challenge
we have is that
Africa has an
infrastructure problem.
Some of these villages
cannot be accessed.
There is no road.
So people come from
a village and say,
"We want your fuel."
But there's no road
connecting to that village.
So that has been a challenge,
how to collect all that.
But I want to thank National
Geographic very much,
because last year
they gave us a grant
that helped us rethink
our business model.
We created something
called franchising...
( laughter )
... which helped us,
micro franchising.
It's not a term we created,
but the model,
we call it micro franchising.
Micro franchising
basically enables us
to eliminate shipping
and transporting things
over long distances.
It enables us to
decentralize our production.
We go to villages.
We find local people who
can manage this business.
Because there are so many
scattered production centers
we can't own all of them.
We will become insane.
So we empower local communities
to manage those businesses.
What National
Geographic did for us
is they gave us money to
create a revolving loan fund
that enables us to
provide the technology
those communities need to
launch these micro businesses,
and within six months
they pay us back,
and then we go to
the next village.
With this, we think we can reach
over 100 million people,
that is slightly over
16.6 million households,
by the year 2030,
stop deforestation,
stop indoor air pollution,
and change the world.
I invite you to our journey.
Thank you very much.
( applause )
( outro music )